you have such a musical ear I mean you
wrote a sketch you know those those
classic Hercules movies you know what
I'm talking about where they're dubbed
they're badly uh they're badly dubbed
and you can tell they're dubbed and the
the the lips don't quite match up and I
remembered uh I'm pretty sure uh it was
Bill Murray yeah in it and you were the
voice of the dubbing yes it was
um a Hercules
uh it was the return it's called The
Return of Hercules and I want always
want to do a dubbing piece like based on
the old again for someone born when I
was in the 50s these Hercules movies
were constantly on because they they
just uh um they're on like Saturday
afternoon and and it was just the
hilariously bad dubbing and um so
uh it was uh Dana played like the evil
King David Carvey Anora Dunn was the
beautiful girl who is Hercules you know
love interest and um and then it's Billy
as Hercules and um it was me and then
the sound booth was me Tom Davis and Jan
Hooks yeah and and I'm doing Billy's
voice and and another like a a guard or
something and Davis is doing the evil
King he's famous part and and then and
Jan was doing Nora's voice and so we
were doing it live and they were like
flapping their lips to sort of the
actors are just moving their mouths yeah
yeah but but sort of trying to you know
it it had to sort of look like they
wanted to be 60 on it you know and so um
but it was just the whole premise was
that Hercules was was out of shape so I
don't remember too many of the details
but it was like um
it was this is Tom doing Dana's
character but uh the the evil King is
going
I will make you this offer you know if
um
if you could uh uh if you could pass a
test with friends
and it's like and so and so then
Hercules what kind of test did you hit
did you propose
what kind of test do you propose it's
like do you see that Boulder no one it
is that giant bowler no one has ever
lifted it if you can lift that Boulder I
will spare the girl's life and then and
then I go and then I go
I'm sorry that Boulder is too large I
can lift a smaller one
such a non- Hercules thing to say that
holder is true anyway like a smaller one
and so he's he pulls a muscle trying to
lift the Boulder and then so they may I
can't remember yeah but it was just it
was just like goofy stuff like um it's
Hercules disgusting he's like oh my God
the mighty Hercules I don't mean to be
cruel but you have really Let Yourself
Go and Hurricane's like I learned to my
sorrow laities that that if you don't
keep up your exercise regimen the muscle
turns to fat
I later I basically was doing Lee Van
Cleef yeah yeah you know but basically I
later used Mike Myers asked me to do
that voice for Wayne's worlds I was the
voice of her father yeah of the girl's
father who was played by the actor James
Hong anyway that was my voice well
[Music]
we're encroaching on your Arizona now
when you were doing the voice I was like
that sounds like the part in Wayne's
World where she's like trying to yeah
yeah uh so um
there was a piece that you did that I
think of as a quintessential Jim Downey
Peach and this piece this is when I was
there so this is in the late 80s early
90s but you did a piece a commercial
parody it was for a bank that would just
make change change Bank
it occurred to me there was something
that just delighted me so much and it's
very popular online and you can you can
you should go and check it out because
you're you star in the piece because no
one could do it as well as you and
you're the spokesperson for change bank
and it was you over explaining yeah yeah
what we do at change bank if you know if
you give us a five we'll give you four
ones and four quarters we'll also give
you and and and breaking it down into
all the denominations and I remember
talking to Jack Handy about this and we
and he was like nobody loves to over no
one loves The Comedy of over explaining
more than Jim Downey telling you much
more than you need to know and it's a
very specific way
and there's a music to it you have a
musical ear for I mean that kind of
Comedy but it is something that always
made me laugh just
deliberately wasting someone else's yes
yes yes like explaining something to
them that
needs no explanation to begin with but
we got it
right and so um and I've done a number
of pieces where that is like a thread
and and I was I remember I remember one
that I'm even sure if it got on but it
was uh when the Padres I think it was
like I was a big Cubs fan when the when
the Padres eliminated the Cubs in 1984
uh 19 it was 1984. I don't know I I
don't care anyway okay but anyway the
the Padres and and the potties are owned
by Joan Kroc the Widow of Ray Kroc who
started McDonald's and uh so I guess it
was a sexist piece I'm sorry Sona but it
was a it was it was Joan Kroc and the
joke was that she didn't know anything
about baseball so she has to address the
team for the game that's like and and um
into the players
I can't stress this enough when you're
at bad hit a home run hit a home run and
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why I
say that because I'll tell you why
because when you when you hit a home run
you get to run around all of the bases
yeah all of them you get to run you
don't know you don't have to stop at all
and and so and uh and the players are
like uh Mrs Croc I mean we like to get
started here you know
um and then so change Bank was just yeah
it was and I wrote that
for Kevin Nealon yeah and and I
and I'm afraid like it was a case of
like I mean you know me I'm not I'm not
like like a bully kind of director guy
but
I was giving Kevin a lot of notes and
Kevin is like you know he was the most
beloved yes it remains I just saw him
yesterday
um everyone you know loved the guy and
and I even and I got even on Kevin's
nerves a little bit and not it wasn't
like a blub I think because Jim maybe
maybe why don't you do it I mean you I
mean I'll be in it you know and and I
actually and I that was one of the very
few times where I I went like
you know actually
I mean I actually would be good for that
just because you need it doesn't hurt
for the it to be played by a person with
no camera presence
yeah yeah I just am I hand on the nerd I
was like the really talking a little too
fast and too excited about something and
um and so that was I'm not I have this
theory that virtually anyone can act in
the right part yes and and there's a
genius in in recognizing what someone
would do really well and
um and and putting them in that right
position and and a great you know
there's a Continuum that ends say it you
know Daniel Day-Lewis say you know we
can do pretty much anything you know
um and then I'm down more the other end
of that